[Music]
zach is with us in sarasota florida hi
zach welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave rachel how are you great what's
up
uh my sister wants to borrow
about five thousand dollars from my wife
and i about
um
um
getting
paying bills and and
just getting through life but she has no
budget no
nothing like that that you preach about
and we're just trying to figure out how
to approach the situation without
causing the rift and go about it
well it doesn't sound promising that
this five thousand dollars is really
going to help her would you agree
uh yeah yeah it wouldn't no
it'd be more yeah
later on and it's more for
legal things and
house and
rents going up as you know with
everything
legal things
um
divorces
she's going through a divorce yes sir
so she wants to pay her attorney bill
pretty much
okay
why is she going through a divorce
yeah it's just a rough
divorce and rough marriage and get
through everything and she it's just not
right for her
she tried to amend everything and it
wouldn't be
it's past it
and you feel like though she has a
pattern
in her life where you don't trust the
yeah so you so you're you're calling us
but you know in your heart
probably not probably not gonna happen
but you're wondering like how to even
communicate that or
correct how can we best help with how
much money do you guys have
oh we're debt-free
how much money do you have
um
500
thousand dollars
yes sir okay and how much do you have
like in uh
savings and checking and so forth you
get your hands on
about 300 000
okay
that's going towards our home that's
that's already
invested money into our primary
homestead home in florida
i'm sorry is that cash in a checking
account or savings account or you've
already paid yeah that's that's now
that's we're building right now oh
you're building and the money is for
your building
correct so this money's earmarked for
your home
but five thousand dollars won't mean you
don't get into the home if you use five
thousand dollars so five thousand
dollars in your life isn't
as big a deal as it is in her life
well so here's the thing um
no i would not i would never under any
circumstances loan
anyone money
particularly people i love because it
changes the nature of the relationship
to borrow her slave to the lender the
odd thing is she will end up resenting
you
for this later
because she will feel like a slave and
she won't even know why it's just weird
and so but what i would be willing to do
is to give it to her
under certain circumstances
if i am participating in her
healing
and moving towards sustainability
fine if i'm participating in chaos which
is what her life appears to be
if i'm participating in irresponsibility
disorganization
and no plan whatsoever to change that
then i'm just giving a drunk a drink i'm
an enabler
that's really not an act of love then
you're right yeah if you love me you
would give me the money and not require
me to change no
the fact that i'm requiring you to
change is part of the gift is because i
love you
as a matter of fact it's the only act of
love in the whole process
so does she live in your town
yes okay
she does um
recommend you and your wife sit down
with her and have a cup of coffee
and your wife doesn't need to say
anything because she'll end up being the
bad guy not because she's her opinion's
not valid but because i don't want her
to be the bad guy this is your sister
okay
but your wife is my wife i'm sorry go
ahead she asked my wife for the money
first and then my wife told me about it
yeah but she went to her first yeah that
doesn't matter you sit down with the two
of you so you show a unified front and
you say listen
here's you got a lot of pain in your
life i'm sorry for what's going on i
want to be a help to you we will not
loan you the money
but i will give you the money under
these circumstances
you're going to go through financial
peace university you're going to get on
a budget
you're not going to borrow any more
money you're going to get and keep a job
and you're going to get in a position to
pay your bills and be a responsible
adult for the rest of your freaking life
and this is your brother talking to you
because i love you
you can thank you and she's likely going
to say no thank you or she's going to
say yes okay i can do that and in our
heart of hearts probably wants to
because everything you just listed out
sounds good and then when you get in the
middle of it or you start it
and it and then and then it goes off so
that's my thing a little bit about the
strings attached with the money like i
totally understand what you're saying
but also
he can't make her do those things so if
you go about that which i'm not saying
is is wrong because what dave just said
but also zach like you have to
emotionally let go
that you you can't force her to do
anything you can suggest and and but
you're gonna give her the money i'm not
gonna give her the money up front
until she does something she's gonna i'm
gonna see some action okay yeah that's
fair does she work
uh yes she works for herself she's
self-employed that she might gain money
she have kids too sorry
she makes money yes but it's all going
towards bills and
everyday living expenses rent
food does she make enough to support the
household after she's
divorced if you help her with five
thousand dollars
no okay so she doesn't make any money
correct she does nothing
compared to her lifestyle too she needs
a job
and to maybe move i mean like seriously
the if your lifestyle is at a certain
point if this was not your sister and
you sat down and just looked at the math
and told her what to do with the math
that's what you need to tell her to do
yeah yeah i got to get your income up i
got to get your out go down that means
you probably can't live in this house
it's too expensive or you can't uh
continue to work this
crummy small business idea that is not
really making you any money and it's an
excuse for you to not work really and so
you've got to go like nine to five and
the kids are going to be in daycare and
i'm going to help you with all that
we're going to coach you we're going to
be your biggest cheerleaders and we're
going to walk alongside you and uh and i
need the money for an attorney okay i'm
going to pay the attorney directly
i'm not giving you the money
and uh and i'm going to be on the phone
with the attorney i want to know what's
going on for the five thousand dollars
i'm giving or the three thousand dollar
retainer i'm giving him the two thousand
dollars is going to these bills okay i'm
gonna write the check to those bills
directly when the ramsey family
foundation comes into
someone's life who's having financial
trouble we pay the bills directly
we do not give them a check zach do you
think if you sat down with her because i
don't know what joel's relationship is
obviously never met but like when you
sit down with her
and say
hey here's what we see just from a math
side this this and this and after the
divorce
here's the right like not like this
isn't going to work mathematically so
we're here to help problem solve to
figure out how to get your life stable
uh where you can breathe again and if
you give suggestions is she the type
that will she want to hear it does she
want help but she just doesn't have
anyone in her life to walk beside her or
not
it just depends on
how she feels at that time
sometimes she just wants the money and
sometimes she doesn't want to hear
anything but the money yeah yeah you
know yes or no and the answer to that
question is no
if all you want is money and you don't
want any help
real help no i have no i have no desire
to participate in
your crazy i'm not i'm not funding it
for you
when you decide you want to get things
straightened up i'll walk with you in a
process to help you get things
straightened up we'll pay for you to go
through financial peace university and
we'll give you the money but don't loan
our money
loaning your money means you expect for
it to be paid back and it changes the
quality and the tenor of your
relationship and i would not do that
i would love her well and be very
generous and give her money if you're
helping her
get traction
back to sanity and sustainability but i
don't want to participate in crazy and
chaos and fund it well